all right slim diamond
absolutely slim diamond where are you
from originally where'd you grow up
i was born and raised in salem alabama
uh born in the
george washington carver projects uh
delivered right there at 134c by
midwife in the late 50s tell me about
your childhood you had both parents
uh no i didn't i knew my father
knew of my father but he was never in my
life um my mother
and uh uncles and grandmother you know
and aunties you know raised me and
i had a pretty good childhood regardless
you know what i mean never wanted for
anything
you know and stuff like that it was
pretty great
and how did pimping come to you um it
started off you know i started off as a
hustler first i went from hustler to
player to pimp in that order
i started off selling weed as a teenager
when i was 17 years old
i got into a relationship with my high
school teacher
and you know that went on for a while
and you know after that same year
i mean the teachers used to give me
money you know like i never had before
sex like i never had before you know
what i mean and uh
that relationship lasted the entire year
you know what i mean that school year
by that summer i was still 17 i went to
detroit michigan
with my aunt and that's when i met a 34
year old prostitute
i was still 17 she was double my age and
she gave me my first
the first money i ever received from a
prostitute was in detroit michigan
she was 34 years old
how many girls did you have in your
stable at one time
uh the most girls ever had at one time
was five prostitutes
i had a lot of different chicks that did
different things you know with me
at that same time but actual prostitutes
that most i've ever had at one time was
five
uh other chicks that i had with me at
that same time were like
you know every chick you know they're
not cut out to be a good prostitute you
know what i mean some of them were just
hustlers
and uh i had boosters i had girls that
you know used to live things you know
going to clothing stores and booths and
stuff like that
but uh at the at one time the most
prostitutes i've ever had was five i was
five deep
at you know at one time and sometimes
these girls are doing things other than
just sex for money
right they're they're oh absolutely you
know all of them all of my chicks were
thieves you know i mean i trained them
to be thieves
uh i trained them to peel tricks like a
banana you know i mean i wanted them to
strip them butt naked
uh every once in a while you know chick
may have like a good client
and it and it wasn't feasible for them
to try to take him for it for what he
had because he was paying them too good
and they would just blow a good a good
trick like that but uh
cats just running the meal cass that
they would meet out on the blade out on
the track
stuff like that hey you may not never
see this cat again so you know take him
you know strip him
stripping butt naked you know and take
him for whatever he had and that was
just uh
you know just a a regular thing in in in
the pimp game with prostitutes did you
have any role models or any anyone that
helped you
oh yeah show you the ropes starting out
absolutely uh you know i had cats you
know
everywhere you go in this country in
this world from coast to coast
you know you're gonna have uh
prostitutes and uh you're gonna
have uh guys that they mess with you
know your prostitution is
is the oldest profession in the world
you know what i mean and uh
one thing about that is like even your
your coming housewife you know
every i like i say it like this uh mark
uh every chick got a little bit of hole
in them
every chick i mean even the common
housewife you know what i'm saying
and uh what i mean by that is like from
an early age from early on
females are taught you know the value of
that little
snack box that they have down there you
know what i mean and uh their parents
you know either their mother
they learn this thing from their mother
their aunts or their relatives or
neighbors or whatever like that
uh that to use that sex that snack box
as a bargaining tool to barter and trade
for the things that they want to need
and they also been taught to use that
sex as
leverage in a relationship in any
relationship that's that's your basic
your common housewife or or any
female any female i don't care whose
wife she is what
position she holds what titles you hold
in life they all
use sex as a means of leverage and also
uh as a means of of a reward uh
when you bring home the bacon uh and
when you pay those bills they'll reward
you with sex
and uh they may even give you a little
oral on your birthday or something if
you
square a lamb you know they hold that
back for certain special dates you know
when you bring home the bacon you dig
and also they'll use sex as a means of
punishment
when you don't you dig they will lock
them legs on you and you gets
nothing i don't care how you don't know
what you're doing if you stop bringing
home that bacon
that coming housewife you know she will
lock them legs on you you won't have
anything coming jack believe that so
that's why i say that
all women have a little bit of hoe in
them you know what i mean that
prostitutes you know i like to use the
word prostitute but
in my world we use the word pimps and
hoes and pimps and hoes lead love
too you know what i mean so that's why
basically
these women uh choose a cat like me of
catamac caliber
which is a rare breed of cat because we
don't detect cats who will accept what
they do
and actually uh encourage them and help
them to do what they do even better
you know what i mean the average cat a
lame or what we consider square or lame
he's he's not going to want her to share
that snack box
he want that thing all to himself as a
matter of fact he could might even want
to kill her
about her own uh genitalia you know what
i mean
so so so they have to miss so so they're
attracted to a certain caliber of cat
and that's the pimp so would you have
sex with your girls
uh absolutely some of them uh i have had
chicks though mark that
uh i never touched i have gotten tons of
money up out of the chick
and to this day i've never touched them
i wasn't attracted to all of these
chicks
in order for me to want a chick i don't
care what kind of money she brings she's
going to have to be
some someone that i'm attracted to or a
chick that i like
you know what i mean and and some of
them it was just strictly business
you know like that and uh you know some
of them didn't even
hang around long enough for me to to do
that you know to
to think about having sex with them
because the name of the game was is cop
and blow
you know they come come going you know
what i mean they come in the front door
looking for the back
you know what i mean so the thing as a
pimp what i would do
is grind them out for as long as i had
them
you know what i mean i i know exactly
what they need and that was to
bust that concrete to their toes bleed
you know keep them out their honest you
know what i mean encourage them to do
what you're doing to keep them
active in the game and so they would
give you
100 of the money pardon me they give you
all their money
absolutely i didn't do no negotiating
i didn't make bargains or deals no
compromising
all the cheese i'm paying all the bills
i'm taking care of the chicks i'm making
sure that
not only she's fed clothed house but her
kids as well a lot of these chicks got
children that wasn't mine
you know what i mean and uh you know
even sometimes their parents you know we
had to break them off
you know what i mean some of them
parents that knew what i was doing they
encouraged them to stay with me because
i was a good cat
i'm not saying that i didn't put my pimp
hand down sometimes i would have to get
physical with them
you know what i mean and lay pimp pimp
hands on them and bless them what i
asked for
that was just part of the game you know
what i mean when they violate you dig
but because uh i rule with iron fist you
know i mean i
i didn't tolerate insubordination from
my chicks period
you know i'd rather see them go you know
what i mean than to to hang around me
and violate my rules and regulations of
my game
you dig and uh were drugs a part of the
picture for your girls
farming where drugs are part of the
picture for your girls some of them did
drugs but that wasn't something that i
condoned
my my whole thing was to to to get them
off drugs
uh mark you know what i mean i never was
a pimp to
to uh get abroad and by means of drugs
because when you do that you're not the
pimp the dope is the pimp
you know what i mean and so so so a pimp
that does that that's a scavenger pimp
you know what i mean uh you know he's
not pimping them at all like i said the
dope is pimping them
you got a chick out here on the blade as
soon as you get get the money she's
going to run to the dope boy she's not
going to bring that money to you she's
going to your money always going to be
short
so but i i have especially down here in
l.a
when i was you know knocking chicks down
here and pimping out these different
hotels they didn't have a track
sometimes we would run brawls right here
on 7th street but i was mostly macking
out the hotels the cecil the hayward
the huntington the rods and the frontier
you know the terminal you know i was
putting brawls down and stuff like that
doing things
you know a lot of these chicks some of
these chicks had uh cocaine habits
some of them had heroin headaches i mean
heroin habits and some of them had
uh crystal meth habits you know what i
mean and uh
i would always try to take them away
from that you know and when they
wouldn't
you know uh adhere to that uh and try to
get some treatment or whatever get some
help
then they just had to go because uh i
couldn't stand to keep them around like
that because they were
intolerable man it's hard to deal with
these type chicks but i'll tell you one
thing
from experience that i i i had better
dealings with heroin addicts females
than i did with crack crackhead chicks
because it was just no telling
no no understanding with those chicks
man so no that wasn't part of my game
you know what i mean
and what about you i've done drugs i've
done every kind of drug it is you know
what i mean
uh uh you know uh cocaine heroin
uh crystal meth uh i've smoked sherm for
a while
but i've been cleaning now for almost 20
years
absolutely 20 years you know i kicked
that you know what i mean and uh you
know and
and i've been had a better life ever
since that's what actually kept me at
the penitentiary
i started going uh as long as i have
been out now
this is the longest i've been out of
penitentiary since the 70s man
i started going to jail in the 70s in
the late 70s
you know uh like i said i was a
marijuana dealer at that time i never
sold narcotics heroin or cocaine
i started off as a cat selling weeds you
know
down south and i ended up getting a
trafficking case uh when i was in my
early 20s and they gave me 15 years
down in alabama for that and i ended up
doing seven years you know down there
and i did three years and four months
out here so for collective
ten years and four months you know
incarcerate actual incarceration time
have you been in love before absolutely
uh i had a chick that uh
i got my kids but i got three sons by a
chick
and uh she was not a prostitute but she
was she was a hustler she was a top
grade a hustler
and she she brought it in and she did
what she had to do
she was a booster and she was a top
top-notch hustler she sold weed for
being different things like that
and when i went to penitentiary man she
stood by me
and she risked her life with me she took
care of my family
uh she risked her life for me by
smuggling drugs into prison for me for i
was
prisoner the first time three years and
this chick did everything in the world
to help me you know and like i said
risked her life and freedom
and so when i got out like i said i
already had three kids by her
i felt you know okay about marrying this
chicken i married this chick
you know we went to the preacher over at
his house over on church street down at
selma
uh reverend shannon and just did it just
like that you know and to this day we're
still married you know i mean even
though and she knew everything that i
did
and we never got a divorce we've been
separated now 20 years
but uh we stayed together almost 21
years that chicken eye
and i and i loved her you know what i
mean and i've loved a lot of different
brawls
you know i mean i love some of my
prostitutes you know like i said pimping
holes need love too
you know what i mean and it was like it
wasn't a square love
it's a different kind of love it's pimp
whole love you know and and
and and that's what it is you know what
i mean but pimps and hoes he loved to
and and i definitely had love for for
several of them i think maybe about
three
in my entire life women that i actually
cared
emotionally about i try not to get an
emotional attachment
and a lot of pimps do you know get
emotional attachment but they try to
to uh you know cover that up and and
keep their feelings in check
but but it'll slip up on you man you
know what i mean and uh you'll find
yourself loving these chicks you know
that you're having deep feelings for
these chicks
you know what i mean what's more
important to you love our money um
well you know what i mean i like money
man you know what i mean i got to have
money because we we got to have that to
survive
you know i've done like so much time in
incarceration time
and and i did that without love but even
in there you got to have money you got
to have somebody putting money on your
books you got to have money to pay your
bills you know what i mean so
love takes a back seat to getting cash
to getting cheese and cheddar you dig
so you got to have your money man you
know what i mean but but no life
is complete without love i always got
love in my heart
you know for for my fellow man for for
anybody that i've dealt with over a
period of time i get emotionally
attached to them that's just my nature
you know i mean
everything is made from love you know
what i mean
the uh the laws have changed drastically
since you've been doing it
oh absolutely and uh is that why you've
kind of gotten out of the game
uh that has some something something to
do with it
that's not in totality but uh you know
like the penalty
is too great for me to even think about
doing i'm in my early 60s now
and i couldn't see one thing i i learned
like when i i didn't want to be
a old man in the penitentiary during
time because i first went to prison when
i was in my early twenties
like i said i did prison time in the
early 80s i went back to a prison time
in the in the 90s
and i did prison time in the early 2000s
so
i chunk here chunk there my life looking
like swiss cheese i got holes all
throughout my
my life you know what i mean my absence
from my family and my loved ones i lost
loved ones while i was incarcerated
so yeah you know uh the laws have
changed greatly
uh they got a new thing uh the
uh palermo protocols you may have heard
of it uh whereas uh
it's uh for suppressing uh human
traffickers and
and and and child molesters and
and kidnappers of women and stuff like
that and uh
but i like to say off the top that human
traffickers are not pimps
and pimps are not human traffickers you
know what i mean i never kidnapped a
brawl
you know they said things got to be bad
you know the whole game has got to be by
choice not by force
you know what i mean but according to
the palermo protocols
you know however you do it you know by
force
fraud or coercion you know you can't
even you know uh encourage your chick to
do that
you know because they'll get you by
force fraud or coercion
and and i learned that from a cat out of
chicago named king burke
he's the one who helped me to that you
know uh uh in a documentary he did i had
never even heard of that i'm still out
here active doing things
and this stuff that you need to learn
you need pimps or any cat in their life
need to
uh read up on these things you know what
i mean to see what these charges are
because they're associating us with
human traffickers
and the time is that they're giving
pimps now is the
type time that they would give someone
that's actually a human trafficker
someone that's kidnapping chicks and and
kidnapping babies and young girls and
putting them out there
like i say to me that's not pimping you
know that's miss pimping
you know i mean even though you have a
reputable pimp you got some reputable
pimps who
mess with underage chicks but like i
said it's not pimping that's miss
pimping
and and when they get caught for that
type violation i don't have no sympathy
for them when they go
and have to do that kind of time you
know you
and stuff like that oh yeah but but
other than that uh yeah you know
it's the the chick has got to choose you
that's why we call the truce you got to
come with a choosing feet
you know you can run behind a chick all
you want that's in anything even in a
square relationship
ain't nothing going to work unless the
chick likes you you can beat her head
into the ground you can whoop on or
whatever
if she don't like you and don't want to
be with you it's not going to happen
you know it's got to be by choice not by
force but that you know and that's what
we used to use to like justify
justify and rationalize you know our
actions with these chicks somebody you
know people think we're monsters and
stuff like that
you know what i mean they say hey well
you know uh you you you exploited and
manipulating that chick but this chick
see prostitutes
you know like i said that's the oldest
profession in the world you know what i
mean and
and and wherever you have prostitutes
you're going to have guys that they like
and love and want to be with
and they're going to have to give that
money to this guy because other than
that why is he going to accept her
you know what i mean so so so yeah man
uh it's got to be by choice not by force
you know what i mean what's the core of
the pimp and prostitute relationship
is the girl trying to recreate the
relationship she had with her father or
or something like that uh in some
instances of the chick they call you
daddy a lot right
yeah and some cats really get off on
that uh
you know what i mean uh you know uh but
but it's nothing to me for a chick to
call me daddy because i see that as game
you know what i mean they'd be trying to
ease up on your daddy this daddy that
day that like i said some cats eat that
up but it's
it's not something that and some cats
even demand you know that day
that the chick called him daddy and in
some instances like
back to your question uh some of those
broads do uh
want uh a father figure and they look to
the pimp as a father figure
you know what i mean the pimp is her
everything you know what i mean not just
her father figure but her lover
you know her guide you know her
spiritual advisor and everything and
that's what you want to be to a chick
you want to be everything like that
but uh you know like i said a lot of
time when they when they come with that
it's just drag you know what i mean the
chick you know and they know
they use game to play on our emotions
too you know what i mean like a chick
call you hey daddy
you feel good about that you know it
makes you feel good so it's acceptable
when i get digging and so i've had some
call me that
but most of my chicks just call me slim
what are you proud of stuff barbie now
what are you proudest of in your life
uh you know getting myself together and
uh
you know trying to live a better life
for my family and for my kids you know
what i mean coming up
from not being a criminal anymore see
everybody got the right to change
you know what i mean i had been see i
was i've been a criminal all my life
since i was a teenager
you know i started off at 13 14 years
old
boosting out of stores you know and then
about 15
a friend of mine rock joe he put that
weed sack in my hand i started selling
weed at 15 about 17 i was a player
like i said i knocked my school teacher
first you know and i had a relationship
with her she paid me she was the one to
give me my re-up money
you know what i mean it was a grocery
store across the street from where she
lived
and and i i would go to grocery store
with her to shop she would buy food and
stuff for us to eat
and and uh the people in the grocery
store saw me with the school teacher
and uh they got so familiar with me that
she would write me checks
when i was 17 years old and i'd take the
checks over there and cash the checks at
the grocery store you know what i mean
and uh get money from this lady you know
what i mean so
yeah you know you must have some
interesting stories for me
oh yeah absolutely but let me finish
that without what i was saying about
being a criminal
uh like every day mark uh you know for
most of my adult life every day that my
foot hit the flow
every day that i woke up and i footed
the flow you can best believe there were
going to be multiple
multiple felonies that were going to be
committed every day of the week every
day of the year
i was a career criminal i mean talking
about felonies that could get you
penitentiary time
you know what i mean and that's all i
did my entire
adult life you know i had a job here
there but
that just wasn't my bag you know i mean
working on a square job that just wasn't
my thing
everybody that knows me can attest to
that you know what i'm saying but just
like malcolm x said
you know there's no disgrace in being a
criminal you know what i mean at having
been a criminal
you know the disgrace is to remain one
you know what i mean and malcolm x
himself had been a pimp and a criminal
and all that before he converted islam
and
got his life on the right track not like
i'm trying to follow malcolm x or
anything
you know i got my own life and i got my
own thing but uh i'm proud of the fact
that uh
i was caught up in a uh a a a trend of
unaccomplishment
you know i'd say i was gonna do
something today i said i was gonna do
this i want to do that and i never do it
and finally when i went to prison the
last time i completed that
you know a book i wrote a book and
that's what i wanted to do
and i wanted to uh you know not write a
book about
how to pimp not a a instructional guide
to being a pimp
not a mac manual or anything like that
but just you know just write a book
see my my my story is a cautionary tale
you know uh i i don't try to encourage
anyone to
to go into the life and i don't try to
encourage anyone to get out of it
you know just do your thing but do it
the right way and
and be a man at what you're doing you
know what i mean because see the thing
about
the pimp game uh whatever you touch
also touches you you know what i'm
saying so so so so uh
you know here you are you think you're
playing the game but the game is
actually in reality playing you
you know what i mean so so uh do your
thing but always try to be the best at
it
and and and not the most abusive cat
you know that not a gorilla pimping all
that trying to force you because you get
washed up out here in this game like
that
so so i'm proud of the fact that i
changed my life around
and uh trying to be a little bit more
productive and that i'm
able to uh pay my bills without having
to be a criminal
you know at this age in the game you
know what i mean who wants to like you
know uh
uh another cat a great cat i like to
quote uh muhammad ali
he said that if you catch a cat in his
50s
that's still doing the same thing that
he was doing in his 20s man that cat has
hadn't grown at all no growth at all you
know what i mean
you 30 years you're doing the same thing
you stuck on stupid
you stagnated you stymied you stifled
stuck on stupid you know so that's not
something where i wanted to be like that
i wanted to be able to excel and grow
you know as a human being
you know you know because there's more
to me than just a pimp uh you know uh
you got the first be a man that's the
title uh pimp
hustler mac ism whatever subtitles which
is cool
you dig but but but you got to be a man
you know and so
so that that's my goal you know to be a
successful human being a successful man
not just for myself but for everybody
who loved me and cared about me my
family my kids
i got grandkids you know and i just want
to be a better a better slim diamond you
dig
so so that's what's up mark awesome
thank you so much for sharing your story
man i i appreciate that and uh uh
you know i got so much more to tell but
i'd like to say this before i go
that uh you know for all you cats out
there
there's uh three types of people in this
game
those that make things happen those that
watch things happen
and those that wonder what happened
therefore you've either got to
lead someone follow someone or get the
[ __ ] out the way
you dig that slim diamond for the record
mr slim diamond
hollywood division palms up [ __ ]
all right so thank you hey man
appreciate you man
was that cool that was awesome
you